go watch John Oliver's whole segment in
its entirety please take into account
the context and you will see that he
undeniably contradicts himself and is
advocating for a system that he admits
could cost more and he admits will
remove more choices you know I want to
ask you before we move on to this
rebuttal here with John Oliver how many
Americans who support socialized or
universal health care do you encounter
in your day to day life and we in the
real world not on Twitter who are
actually familiar with how these health
care systems work and the real-world
results seen abroad I want to know how
many people you encounter who actually
have that information as opposed to sort
of the fairy tale version that John
Oliver and others try to sell them in
which we will get to so let's set this
up we've addressed some of these
arguments before so I don't want to
retread all of our socialized healthcare
territory you can just type in steven
crowder healthcare if the search results
worked but they don't so they're dead
forever so you never get to see them
again
you'll never get all the way down but
there are some arguments that that John
Oliver sort of focuses on that I think
we could do a better job of addressing
because a lot of people they buy that
ship so let's go to out John Oliver
first clip Medicare for all I lived in
England short nationalized healthcare is
a disaster when rich famous people get
sick this America does have one of the
best health care systems in the world
for rich famous people unfortunately too
many people are born in this country
with a terrible pre-existing condition
called not being honest and informative
if only sort of miss informative effects
so let's let's that really quickly don't
wanna spend too much time on this we
already have Medicaid for the poor as we
will get to nationalizing health care
just makes it worse for everyone
furthermore in countries with socialized
health care there's inevitably an
underground market where only the super
wealthy can afford what is equivalent to
what we know is privatized care here in
the United States for example my mother
in Quebec at this point before shall we
versus Quebec was a Supreme Court case
you couldn't get any privatized health
care she need
MRI it was 12 12 months I believe her 14
months now a little bit of cash grease
the palms with $900 she got an MRI
within six that's an improvement that's
definitely so high long and all of these
other socialized healthcare countries
you end up with more of a two-tiered
system where only is super wealthy can
afford it because we're not to under
crippling taxes let's go to the next
clip and then I want to come back at you
the majority of people who file for
bankruptcy cite medical expenses as a
factor and you probably already knew
that deep down from just how often you
see GoFundMe campaigns online no but
first you had something was wrong I was
gonna say that the previous guy he
wasn't rebutting the point that that
it's expensive sometimes to get great
medical health he was just basically
saying everybody that says the US has a
really bad system is wrong because of
this right and so I think John Oliver's
just taking as far as this to medical
bankruptcies it is it is wrong no your
honor the defense is wrong uses a
methodology of inflates the numbers how
these studies just confirmed that people
who went bankrupt also claimed that they
had medical expenses in other words they
had many expenses if any of those
expenses listed were medical expenses
John Oliver and the like are people of
the TYT Network will claim that the
majority or a huge portion of
bankruptcies come from exclusively or
primarily medical expenses review if you
actually look at the data the number is
somewhere between 12 and 17 percent okay
and by the way this doesn't even mean
that medical expenses were actually the
problem if you go bankrupt if you go
bankrupt because you have no job or you
have no insurance and you can't pay your
medical bills is that a medical bill
problem or is it an unemployment problem
and I think this is you know cut off the
head of the dragon if we look at
bankruptcies as a whole this is
important because I think I think John
Oliver is someone who in good faith is
trying to find the right solutions I
just think that is wrong but if we look
at bankruptcies and I agree I think we
should be compassionate
I think bankruptcies are a problem we
should do what we can within the bounds
of a legitimate purview of government to
try and reduce them it doesn't mean that
you take money out of my back pocket and
basically light it ablaze which is
effective what the federal government
does yeah but I think if we can create a
safety net that doesn't infringe on
individual rights if run vehicle a sure
so let's look at bankruptcies because
that's the root cause of this problem
here they had a huge spike yeah
about I think we have a 60,000 a year in
2010 under the Obama administration then
they dropped they've stay below
consistently under President Trump
compare that by the way to the yearly
unemployment rate it's almost identical
these graphs same spike in 2010 Wow so
what does all this means what does all
this means all wish me yeah means you
cut pick-a-pocket why would you pick a
pocket it's just a stereotype I'm
perpetuating yes oh jeez xx you read all
about it so the medical expenses I'm not
the driving force behind bankruptcy if
you don't have a job any big expense is
going to cause bankruptcy and so as a
conservative I want to create an
atmosphere go with the free enterprise
system that brought us here that allows
us to have the lowest unemployment
highest job participation and most
legitimate wage growth of any other
system throughout the globe or human
history ever next clip we will be
getting a lot for that money
remember 27 million more people would be
covered and they'd be covered
well Bernie's plan is incredibly
generous it covers vision dental
long-term care and drugs in fact
medicare for all is a misleading title
because Medicare requires some co-pays
and out-of-pocket expenses and Bernie
will excitedly tell you his plan
eliminates those under the Medicare for
all bill that I wrote premiums are gone
co-payments are gone deductibles are
gone all out of pocket expenses are gone
so we're just promising sure we can't
deliver okay free pipes you got yours
right by the way you have to fix that
Prop there afterwards disingenuous how
do I know ask me how I know I was raised
in a country
and I know there's difference between
socialized health care universal health
care we're going to use the term
somewhat interchangeably because that's
kind of what they're advocating here
yeah all countries if you know some
exceptions let me know with universal
coverage systems they mandate some kind
of co-payments for outpatient
pharmaceuticals cost there's
cost-sharing for inpatient hospital
stays out-of-pocket costs K that can
range from I think was 15% for health
health costs for Canadians where I was
from to 28% for people in Switzerland
all the way up to 61% for health
expenditures in Singapore by the way
they can also bend you over in front of
your wife and spank your ass with a came
because you spat gum on the sidewalk so
there's a give-and-take
yeah it's a benevolent dictatorship they
put an embarrassing one but look I don't
have to step in gum and I appreciate
that but if you outlaw hubba bubba
then only hubba bubba dealers will have
them oh that's right that's a proper
created a black market for coming
bubblicious notwithstanding that's a
whole different brood the Crips okay
let's go to the next look where he talks
about how much it would cost and how it
would be worth it this is another
coconut you can't definitely say that it
would be more expensive but even if it
was I personally would argue that it's
worth it and either way cost is a lot
more complicated and issue than just
going on TV and saying 32.6 Tyrolean
dollars like Tina Fey doing her best dr.
evil impression okay
so first you won't you can't say that it
would be any cheaper and admit that the
majority of the studies say would cost a
ton more which it does in this segment
second John all over your complaint
right now is that people can't afford
health care ok now you're looking at
possibly spending more for a worse
product by your own admission you are
looking at potentially spending more for
crappier service keep in mind to
Bernie's tax plan this is something
where he talks about you know taxing the
top one percent then it moves to five
percent then it moves to ten percent
depending on how many books he sells
that year his plan will tax everyone who
makes twenty nine thousand dollars a
year or more there will be increased
taxes
that's hardly someone living in the lap
of luxury exactly so we need to be clear
about this now when people oliver say
people like oliver they say that
universal health care would be better
this is something that really bothers me
that i want to focus on k they often
cite studies like Thea I think the World
Health
report okay there are two studies that
people cite when they say the United
States doesn't have the best health care
we've gotten into this before
there's the Commonwealth study that has
11 countries ranked they have the United
States ranked 11th and then the UK
ranked number one yeah and then there's
the the it's often referred to as a who
report that sort of lists everyone
across the globe this is often cited as
well and we've addressed it in the past
but let's start this off we ranked 37th
the United States in the world okay this
is by the way when people say we don't
have the best health care they are
citing two studies this one and the
Commonwealth study that's it okay so
we've talked about how some of them are
BS because they take into account
irrelevant sort of measurements of quote
like self reporting or personal
satisfaction polls in other words people
say well my health care and then in
previous videos we've compared American
health care to say like up the UK right
or Canada and we've been trying to use
objective parameters right things like
wait time survival rates you can go back
and search them if the searches worked
in other words don't search them you'll
just never find them again so you don't
exist
yeah nothingness but then I realized
that we are holding American health care
to a much higher standard than people
like Bernie Sanders or the poll takers
themselves they're all there are all
kinds of countries outside of the UK or
Canada that are ranked above the United
States based on the leftist criteria the
kind of criteria that Bernie would use
so the citizens of Chile are there on
month for right now protests against the
government because of these unbearable
costs of living what do they say
education health care costs as some of
the worst donors also by the way this
should be relevant to people like Bernie
the wait times to get you know stents
this is a procedure a hard procedure
that bernie has done recently we need
heart attack in Chile's between 44 to 52
days yeah
or sorry it's between 44 to 50 days in
UK sure yeah I don't know what it isn't
sure I'm sure it's pretty bad too
neighborhood there is in the UK public
schools guess what the wait time is in
the United States hmm 90 minutes 90
minutes another one in those Columbia so
they're 15 spaces above us so that would
be 22 I can do the math quickly I just
can't remember it
a couple of things first up does anyone
out there really believe that coat do
you really believe that Columbia is
better than the United States in health
care and you can look it by the way the
infant
right I usually don't like using that as
a comparison because why we have a much
higher standard yeah so we actually
register our infant mortality rate
higher because we report them as infant
mortality but other countries wouldn't
even consider to life but even using a
far more stringent standard theirs is
nearly double ours or actually I think
it's more than double ours so that's
important to note I mean you're
something to Americans most Americans
they don't want us to have health care
like Colombia or Chile not rented ok but
here's the point the standards by which
Bernie and AOC and Elizabeth Warren that
the Centers they're using to measure
successful health care system they would
determine that Colombia and Chile and
Cuba are undoubtedly better it is what
may would prefer they point to a study
that has them ranked 3 for 15 spaces
above us
even though people can't get stints with
in that same fiscal year then they try
to feed you the lies this appeal to Papa
this appeal to popularity yeah it fells
it that most Americans agree with them
not true no that's not true it's not
true nothing that would make it right by
the way was read at some point you could
find a majority of people who agree with
slavery of course still across the
Islamic world indentured servitude
like I said nice fake ski hills they
over there and then Dubai but guess why
do slaves built that oh you didn't build
that slaves so sure in the abstract yeah
many Americans would like free health
care these are the polls they point you
they don't like yeah hey free health
care that sounds good but most Americans
want to be able to keep their insurance
plan and only 13% of Americans actually
want to completely abolish private
insurance which make no mistake is
exactly what Bernie or Warren's plan
would do by the way please do hit the
notification they'll hit all
notification if you're subscribed than
YouTube because otherwise you and turn
on all the notifications on the YouTube
app otherwise you won't get them and do
consider subscribing to the audio
version of course Mudd Club is the only
way we could that we get to keep the
show going because we do not have over a
hundred employees producers writers and
researchers like John Oliver they're
taking our jobs we don't have the hate
chili pill money okay we don't don't we
just it's a racket mm-hmm if you want to
trust big hate Peruvian Pharma oh here's
another one we talks about I think
waiting lines next clip as we've
cost comparisons of wait times are very
complicated for one thing the
International wait times that you hear
about most often are for non-emergency
surgeries so expense replacement while
yes people in other countries do
sometimes have to wait slightly longer
for some care it's not like Americans
aren't having to do that right now
anyway Americans are just sometimes
forced to wait due to the expense about
half of US adults say they or a family
member put off or skipped care in the
past year because of the cost and about
1 in 8 say their medical condition got
worse because of that delay okay so I'm
gonna give you a little bit of time
there to see if you can spot the ball
now I'll come back to what did you spot
it here's the quote from John Barrie
since half of US adults say they or a
family member right put off or skipped
some sort of health care or dental in
the past year because of the wrong
person in for me that could literally
include my aunts skip the cleaning
because it was $85 and she didn't want
to pay it that day she needed lotto
tickets or a family member that's anyone
in your family and it could be some sort
of health care which seems broad enough
they're getting himself some leeway back
through out or dental care in the past
year because of cost anyone you know and
your family has put off some sort of
health care procedure or dental care at
some point in the last year that does
not mean that people are not able to get
necessary medical procedures or even
preventative care yeah I put off a
cleaning last week because I was out of
town well you always put off the
cleaning there's nothing entirely other
issue we'll talk about another example
here you have people going blind waiting
for basic cataract surgery on the upside
they don't have to see any Britt not
named Elizabeth Hurley or Daniel Craig
so the good Lord giveth you taketh away
but it's not how you want to base a
health care system now next clip as for
the uninsured they can won't wind up
having to wait on a literal line seeking
care with AIDS groups like remote area
medical an organization that travels the
country setting up mobile clinics to
treat people for free and which draws
massive lines wherever it goes
having got their place in line many
can't add for the night
dawn this was the moment they were
waiting for I mean that seems like a
good thing yeah - what is the truth here
ya know he was about breadlines yeah
different line this is groundbreaking
sir the truth is these units they were
made for people in remote areas that
don't really have that many medical
facilities nearby that's why they exist
people waiting outside of a free health
care truck in a rural area without many
doctors is not comparable to blind
people in Manchester waiting one and a
half years to get routine cataract
surgery one is innovation the other is a
pecan tree next clip there is the final
big criticism of Medicare parole which
involves choice specifically that it
would take away our ability to choose
the sort of health coverage that we
receive the fact is our current system
limits Americans choices far more than
it expands them for starters as a
practical matter most of us don't choose
our health insurance we get what we get
through our employer and because of that
choices like changing jobs can become
significantly harder and not just that
oftentimes your choice of doctors and
hospitals is severely limited by which
ones your insurance will cover okay by
the way that does not imply that you
don't have a choice it means that people
choose to have the insurance through
their employer because it's cheaper and
it's partially subsidized by their
employer people who do not have employer
paid health insurance get to choose
whatever they want people who do can
also choose whatever they want but they
often choose to go with the employment
insurance even if it's inferior which is
the exact same example of these
subjective polling parameters used for
people who think that their health care
is better because of socialism by the
way only talks about this that it limits
our choice let's go with everything that
he just says there okay let's just count
everything I've just said and assume
everything that he said was accurate how
is that an argument for removing all
choice okay let's go through this here
and I do I do hope that the search
algorithms work on YouTube because we've
addressed a lot of these other arguments
and we've actually shown people what it
looks like to go through a socialized
healthcare so yeah I think the most
important takeaways here though are
those that World Health Care
Organization ranking and this idea that
somehow this will cost last year it
won't raise taxes even if you watch the
whole segment go watch John Oliver's
whole segment in its entirety please
take into account the car
text and you will see that he undeniably
contradicts himself and is advocating
for a system that he admits could cost
more and he admits will remove more
choice so let me get this straight john
oliver you admit this you admit this
will raise costs you cannot guarantee
that the product will be anything better
than what we currently have all
objective standards available to show
that it will be worse and you john
oliver admit that it will remove any
remaining choices that we have from an
already flawed system and this is your
best argument with over a hundred
writers researchers and producers you
are just the worst i hope you enjoyed
this clip if you don't these are the
ABCs of me baby you can just click Next
video and put it in double speed of
course search doesn't necessarily work
subscriptions notifications don't
necessarily work just bookmark this page
check and we do a new video every single
day except for Sunday and if you don't
want this content to disappear join my
club at laterals credit.com / Mudd Club
it's only $69 if your student Feder
interactive military and if you don't
you know listen I I don't want to say
that you're hell bound but it it doesn't
look good for you